you said taraji that you think comedians
make great dramatic actions why'd you
say that because they add an element of
humor and and the reason why they make
great comedic actors is because a lot of
comedians laugh through their pain
that's that's why that's the defense
mechanism they've come through a lot of
traumatic so you feel this you're about
to cry a lot of you know a lot of
comedians have said that you're using
some pain that's what you learn your
childhood pain or pain when you're young
you can turn it into comedy absolutely
do you think Tracy would make a great
dramatic actor what do you want to see
him play um he played what's the movie
you showed me the clip Cab Calloway no
Louis Armstrong and I was blown away I
you know he Tracy is really I hope you
get get that movie made you're out for
the role of Louie are fantastic yeah
because our lives were in parallel I
really believe this is a beautiful world
with others with all the scams and judge
me and broken dreams it's still a
beautiful place to be yeah would you
like to see him do Shakespeare
[Applause]
Shakespeare I have faith in you
okay all right me doing Shakespeare
check it out to be or not to be that's
question
[Applause]
Shakespeare's Noddy yeah yeah I shake my
spear alright settle down